- [Female] So, just to introduce myself,
my name is Noel Girgenti
I'm an analyst
- I'm aware.
- Great
(laughs)
And so I started last May
- Yes
- So I've almost been here a year
so I'm super excited to finally meet you!
- I'm glad we finally connected,
I'm sorry it took so long.
- No, don't worry about it.
Just happy I have some of your time.
- Tell me about yourself.
- Sure, so I was born and
raised in Brooklyn, New York.
So, right across town basically.
I went to St. Paul University,
I graduated last year with my
Master's degree in Marketing
and I also went there
for Undergrad as well, for
Marketing and Psychology.
- That's awesome.
What can I answer for you?
- So
- Can you find me Marcus?
- Something that I was just
thinking about recently,
since I graduated, I
was in school for like
16 years of my life.
- Yeah.
- And I wanted to transition
a little bit difficult
- Because that was so structured?
- Yes.
- I mean, honestly,
don't beat yourself up.
- Yeah.
- You landed in the right place.
We're not gonna beat you up.
- You don't.
So inviting.
- So, I think you're beating yourself up.
You're five seconds out.
- I know.
- The end.
- 'Cause I feel like I
did so well in school,
I was like, how do I translate that?
- You don't.
But you don't think you can't not.
- No, I just don't know how
- Right, you've got to
get out of that rhythm.
- Yeah.
- You got to get into real life rhythm.
But you're a kid.
You're a kid.
- Yeah.
Only 23.
- Don't beat yourself up if
it's not coming easy yet.
You have to decompose
from that old environment.
- Yeah.
That's
- And then try to do
a couple things that feel uncomfortable.
It's always stretching yourself.
- Yeah, and so that's something too like
finding the motivation to
- Yeah.
- Find different things
to branch out.
I have a lot of interests, but I'm like
I don't know if I could get into that,
I don't know how to get into that,
I don't know the right
steps or people to talk to.
And I'm always constantly
doing it and then
- Pulling back.
- And then, wanting to put up my all here
and then I do that and I'm just,
it's always like
- Yeah I think you need
to deploy some patience.
- Yeah
- That's all.
- I'm sure you have plenty ambitions,
I'm sure you have things you want to
prove to yourself and others.
We all do.
But patience is the absolute
secret sauce to all this.
- Yeah.
That's definitely the hardest part
'cause I always been saying,
yeah you always have
project, three months, you're done.
Like, you did great, A.
And then now it's like,
okay now, like as you always
say, it's a long game.
It's like, alright,
when do you find and seed
the fruits of your labor
come out?
And you never know when it'll happen,
when it'll actually
- Yeah, and it's like
the fruits of your labor
conversation at 23,
to me, is ludicrous.
- Yeah.
- You know?
I get it, but,
I want to get you out of it.
- I know, and
- I was 34 years old when I
left my dad's liquor store,
and like, had nothing.
I built my dad's liquor store for him,
didn't make that much money.
- Yeah.
- And was just starting at 34!
I know, I always think
I think about things like that
and I'm just like why?
You can achieve so much
- Do you feel pressure from
anybody outside yourself?
If you're being honest?
- Well, when I was at school,
I definitely felt pressure from my family,
but not because they would
make me feel pressure
but I feel like I always did well,
you should expect
- Yeah.
- To expectation.
But outside right now, not really,
I think it really comes from within me.
- Yeah.
- And I don't think it's the pressure
that motivates me
- Yeah I mean, look, I think that's right.
I think if you can just figure out if
if you're competitive with
your circle of friends
or things of that nature,
envy, competition, whatever
it could be around that,
super important for you to understand it.
Because once you get,
it's incredibly empowering and happy
once you can calibrate all this.
- Yeah.
And that's, I feel like it's coming
piece by piece.
- Yeah.
- Place where I love.
And then I'm like, okay
but how do I get from here
to full potential?
How do I finally break that mold,
so I'm like, yes!
Like this is so satisfying.
- By trusting the process,
and always auditing if you're complacent
or being patient.
- Right now I'm being patient.
That's for sure.
- But to me,
you're probably not if you're having
this level of complex
You know what advice I would give?
Listen, I don't know enough, yet
but intuitively right
now, in this limited time,
I feel like literally, making a rule
that you can't think
about anything other than
one day at a time, having fun, learning,
being young, for the next 24 months.
Not allowed.
You have to wait to your 25th birthday,
to even start debating
what's happening here
would be monumentally impactful on you.
- I feel like a lot of
pressure taken off my shoulders
just thinking like that.
So,
- You have to understand,
you could do nothing right
for the next seven years,
start putting it together
on your 30th birthday
and still have plenty of
time to achieve everything.
- That makes me feel better.
- I get it.
- Yeah.
(laughs)
- You know what's scary?
It's true.
- Yeah.
And I know you talk about
instant gratification
it's not about that,
and I feel like always
try to break the mold,
okay, I can't get it right now.
I have to just slow down.
- The fact that you're even thinking about
getting it or not getting it
is the problem.
- Mmhmm.
Okay, that makes sense.
- 25.
No judging, no debating, no even pondering
if this is good, bad,
getting you to where you need to or not.
- Okay.
- I'm being serious with you,
I think that gets you to
where you want to get to
way faster than debating
it in the short term.
You need to take a little
steam out of the engine and
take a breath a little bit.
- Okay.
That's
- It will help you.
It'll get a lot more quiet,
which will create a lot more room.
- To be more perceptive
to things and learning?
So, one question that I do have as well.
I'm always thinking influencer market
obviously thinking about the next step
in the career, so
what do you think is a
natural step for that?
So I obviously want to
grow in the department,
but what else can you branch out
- You're gonna learn about
something that has influence in culture.
I think influencer
marketing is one of the best
departments to be in at Vayner.
I think we are figuring out
how to navigate it right now,
it's still in a limbo stage.
But I think you're gonna learn
I think again, I think
your natural planning DNA,
I think you're trying to make a game plan
and attack, you're trying to attack
and I'm trying to have you be more karate,
which is take the force that comes at you
and adjust with it.
- Okay.
- I think influencer
marketing's a really good thing
which is, nobody really
knows where it goes
but learning it is gonna
be highly valuable for you
going forward.
- Yes
- How it works as a media function,
how it works as a cultural function,
how humans interact.
- Yes.
- Look, I think you need to
calibrate your ambition slash insecurity
whatever it is.
100 and zero, 50 50,
you need to take that
pressure out of the system.
- Okay.
- It will work for you.
- You make a commitment.
If you sleep on this and
come back and email me
and say, I'm doing it,
and say, I'm literally
not gonna judge myself
one way or the other
for the next 22 months
until I'm 25,
I think it'd really really
impact you in a positive way.
I really believe that, I'm being serious.
- Awesome.
Yeah.
- You deserve it.
- I work,
work your ass off so much
and you're just like,
where does it go?
But then, 'cause I feel like
like I said the pressure from the school,
they're always asking where
are you gonna go next?
I just wanna be
- Now you're in control.
But you're still latching
onto those behaviors.
- Yeah.
- You gotta fix that.
- Okay.
That is good to know.
(laughs)
- It's awesome.
- It's gonna be so relieving,
thank you so much
- You're welcome
- for your time today
- Have a great day, my pleasure.